i'll also be speaking to a guest from
india coming up um shortly no longer a
member of of the commonwealth but the
colonial ties uh a problem um on
occasion certainly when the queen
visited
yes absolutely and
this is this is something he's going to
have to he and he and camilla who have
been on a lot of doing a lot of
traveling and themselves in their own
right will have to manage very carefully
and remember william after the in the
aftermath of that criticism of that tour
gave gave a well-received speech in
which he said that the monarchy
essentially had to to move with the
times and welcome countries going
independent but remaining friends of of
the uk okay well uh let's bring in our
guests should we miri naya author and
journalist based in
india as we look at these pictures from
the queen's visit back in 1961
good morning t thank you for joining us
can you tell us about uh india's day of
mourning for the queen
it is indeed a very uh sad moment
because the queen was the head of the
commonwealth association
and india is a member of the
commonwealth countries and therefore
the indian tri-color is flying at
half-mast for a day
in memory of the queen's demise
uh however the new generation you know
with its new uh
frenzy of nationalism
is not connected to monarchy the british
monarchy
as our perhaps our parents and
grandparents were
we somehow cannot forget also the
colonial
uh the colonial rule over us for all
these years and uh
incidentally just three months ago india
celebrated her 75th freedom from the
british empire
so it's kind of a mixed emotion where uh
the older members of the society have a
very strong bond with the queen but the
newer generation are speaking about the
kohinoor in her
in her crown which was a jewel of india
and perhaps the other
you know the other history like the
famines and
that which were inflicted on this
country
but however the general mood is she was
a woman
and
she reigned over a country and an empire
for so many years
and therefore as a respect to her the
national flag is a half-past but i think
the
the generation that is of now is losing
connect with the monarchy
certainly uh india is independent as we
know but still a member of the
commonwealth like i think i'm right
insane and uh i think it could be argued
that her majesty had shown respect to
the people of india on several occasions
what three times she visited visited us
that's right she visited us three times
and our prime minister modi has visited
her and earlier too there were visits
from the prime ministers of this country
that's what i said there is a mixed
emotion because uh
we are indeed uh
the the nation honors her with the flag
flying half-mast
but there is this generation also who
who feels differently and who feels that
you know uh that as a colony as a former
colony uh perhaps uh you know we she
could have done more for us
and uh and that's it but on the whole
the mood is very somber
and
the nation does condole her death
and the people of india their view of
king charles
sorry yes yes because
we have a very fond relationship with
the king charles because he has visited
here many times and
with the then princess diana to the taj
and we are really looking forward to see
what are the innovations and the new
things he's going to bring as the new
head of the commonwealth association
and from this country we wish him all
the best for his individuals